good morning believe nation today's
message is don't be a part-time dreamer
over you paulo coelho
[Applause]
[Music]
to me years I knew that I want to be a
writer since I was young and have this
megalomaniac things about being the most
famous writer in the world but it's not
enough to know what you want you have to
to do what you want to be what you want
you know so a writer implies in writing
books yeah
a gardener implies in gardens you know
but if you I don't know about today but
if you talk to your father your mother
if you are from a middle-class I want to
be a gardener a fallacy oh my son please
go to the University yeah get a diploma
Miami country your gardening during that
weekend you know but you love plants you
love this all you will love hello but at
the end of the day you are convinced and
this is not good for the person who is
being convinced it and for the person
who is trying to convince you're
creating this order of frustration
around them so I agree with the intent
of this message I think though that you
can be a part-timer to start I'm not the
guy who says you need to burn all your
bridges and forget about anything
practical and just go all in and burn
all your savings and find a way to make
your dream work and for some people that
really works like for some people to
quit smoke and they need to quit
cold-turkey they can't ease their way
into it to just to quit some people are
all or nothing people that's not me
I like small tests I like small
experiments I like doing things on the
side and trying to turn that into
something so understand first who you
are and how that can you know best apply
to your motivation but I think it's okay
to have something on the side while
you're working the job if you want to be
a singer but you're not making enough
money
from your singing yet and you're not
good enough you need to practice more
and you have to you know bus tables to
pay for your lessons and just to pay for
the internet bill and food
ideally work at a job where you're
actually learning I'm not just doing
some menial tasks but I get it sometimes
you have to work a job to make money to
survive but the key thing is not letting
your side hustle die like while it is
your side hustle now you want it to
become your full-time thing like you're
investing this time and energy into it
on a consistent basis because you want
that to be your full-time career right
and not being talked out of it because
somebody around you your parents your
friends whoever tells you no you can't
you can't be a singer come on you know
you're not you're not really good enough
to be a singer you're too old for that
and you haven't gone to school for that
give you all the reasons why it's not
gonna work and even the voice inside
your head when you listen to your own
stuff and see you know that wasn't
really very good you know that sucks but
it's okay because you got to get better
with more practice and more hustle and
more energy and so even though it's a
part-time thing now I think as long as
you have the intent for it to be a
full-time thing and you fight for your
dream because there's gonna be so many
things that prevent you from doing that
like your job gets super busy or there's
an illness in your family or you know
you just don't feel like waking up and
putting in insane hours today because
life is beating you down there's gonna
be so many different reasons that will
make it hard for you to go off and
pursue your dream but you have to fight
for it's got to be something that you
believe in so much that you're so
passionate about that no matter what
comes no matter who tells you that you
can't do it no matter what lack of
resources you have you're still gonna
get up and go and do it and it's that
passion that keeps you going
so if you're gonna start a part-time I'm
okay with it just make sure that you're
spending time every single day on that
business
no excuses and you're fighting for your
dream so the question today today is I'm
curious if you are full-time or
part-time in your business right now you
can just say full-time or part-time
leave in the comments below really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout-out to Renaud I newland
thank you so much for buying my book
really means a lot to me those are you
washing you want a chance that eyeshadow
in the future video make sure to pick up
a copy of the book and email in your
receipt so we can keep track thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of Enter